je sais pas si vous avez suivi l'actu si
vous le savez il y a une mise à jour
importante qui a fait Apple c'est la
mise à jour de Ios 16.1 nouvelle version
alors déjà je vous ai fait une vidéo il
y a quelques temps pour vous parler des
nouveautés de la USA qui sont super
intéressantes mais iOS 16.1 va plus loin
Apple a intégrer des nouveautés qu'ils
avaient présenté mais qui n'était pas
présente dans iOS
16.1 j'ai 11 nouveautés intéressants
très intéressantes qu'il faut connaître
pour pouvoir les utiliser correctement
vous êtes prêts vous êtes prêts on est
parti
tout se passe ici dans votre iPhone on
s'en doutera iOS 16 c'est iPhone ios.0
s'arrête l'iPhone une fois plus j'ai pas
moins de 11 nouveautés super
intéressantes à venir vous présenter la
toute première on la voit c'est l'icône
au niveau de la batterie alors je sais
pas si vous avez suivi mais c'est un
truc qui est arrivé ca iOS 16
c'est-à-dire vous avez votre pourcentage
de batterie qui est juste là sauf
caillot 16 il faisait très mal vous
aviez le pourcentage c'est toujours à
fond vous avez votre niveau de batterie
en fait tout blanc à fond et vous aviez
le chiffre ce qui fait que quand je vais
regarder rapidement comme ça j'ai
l'impression que c'est à fond et en fait
des fois vous aviez 30 20% bref vous
avez plus beaucoup de batterie donc
Apple est venu corriger ça parce qu'il y
a quand même eu pas mal de retours
négatifs maintenant vous avez non
seulement le pourcentage mais aussi le
niveau de batterie qui descend c'est
beaucoup plus visuel alors si vous ne
savez pas je vous montre comment venir
l'activer vous venez ici dans vos
réglages de réglages vous allez dans
batterie et dans batterie vous venez
activer pourcentage de la batterie comme
ça vous avez votre pourcentage vous
voyez qui se met juste là avant vous
avez cette icône qui était un petit peu
plus classicos vous cliquez c'est déjà
beaucoup plus joli c'est plus clair ça
pas mal du tout donc ça c'est le premier
point et c'est bien qu'Apple soit nul
corriger le deuxième point c'est les
activités en direct c'est un truc
qu'Apple avait présenté la double you WC
au mois de juin l'année dernière on
attendait que iOS 16 et qui n'arrive
qu'avec iOS 16.100 en fait je vous
explique vous allez avoir différentes
applications qui vont pouvoir continuer
de présentage de fond je regardais par
exemple là j'ai ça c'est à dire que ça
c'est une application qui me permet
d'avoir un suivi un tracking d'un vol
donc là je vois que mon vol est déjà
arrivé et je vois qu'en plus je peux
venir alors je c'est un faux vol je l'ai
je suis dans l'application mais moi je
ne vole pas il y a pas d'avion
aujourd'hui et je vois que je peux
récupérer les bagages directement ici au
numéro 5 donc là je vais le retrouver là
mais je le retrouve pas que là regardez
j'en ai verrouillé et de la même manière
regardez vous allez le retrouver juste
ici dans dynamic Island alors il faut
que vous ayez un iPhone 14 pro ou un
iPhone 14 pro max et si c'est le cas
d'un dynamic Island vous le retrouvez
vous avez qu'à cliquer dessus et hop
vous avez accès à toute votre
information donc je trouve le truc assez
marrant vous voyez je l'ai là que
j'appuie il arrive je le remonte il
retourne là-haut et je l'ai directement
là donc ça c'est extrêmement pratique
alors vous pouvez l'avoir bien
évidemment avec cette application là
vous pouvez également la voir avec
Hubert ou votre taxi va arriver vous
pouvez la voir avec un suivi d'un match
quelconque vous l'avez également avec le
timer regardez par exemple je me mets un
petit un petit minuteur hop là il
démarre hop je sors et j'ai mon minuteur
également ici qui continue à être là
alors je peux les cumuler j'ai le
minuteur là j'ai ça également ici c'est
plutôt pratique et de la même manière
lorsque je viens déverrouiller je l'ai
au niveau de Dynamic Island donc là j'ai
le suivi de mon vol qui est là et ici je
vais avoir mon timer les deux donc ça
c'est plutôt pratique deuxième nouveauté
qui est vachement bien peut venir
personnaliser son écran d'accueil
beaucoup plus facilement voyez par
exemple ici je viens j'appuie vous
connaissez et ensuite je peux venir
personnaliser c'est pas tout nouveau on
l'avait déjà k iOS 16 iOS 16.1 va un peu
plus loin je clique sur Personnaliser et
là je peux venir personnaliser
indépendamment mon écran de verrouillage
et mon écran d'accueil donc je peux le
faire comme ça sinon ce que je peux
faire je viens ici dans mes réglages
dans mes réglages je viens dans fond
d'écran et dans fond d'écran regardez je
les trouve tous les deux côte à côte et
je peux venir les personnaliser
indépendamment si je veux dire
personnalisé par exemple que cette
partie là et bien je peux le faire
couleur dégradé photo flou et j'ai pas
obligé de le faire de la même manière
sur l'écran du rouillage et sur l'écran
d'accueil autre nouveauté qui est
intéressante l'application maison a
ajouté accessoires matter donc prends en
charge mater le colmateur qui permet un
peu de tout unifier donc si vous avez
des produits compatibles matter ça y est
mateur arrive directement ici dans iOS
autre truc qui est intéressant c'est
l'album photo partagé vous allez dans
votre application photo et vous allez
ici dans vos albums partagés vous pouvez
donc venir partager un album avec des
amis par exemple ici j'ai quelques
photos et vous voyez que vous avez la
petite icône juste en haut pour venir
ajouter des amis donc on pouvait venir
inviter des amis ça c'est plutôt
intéressant et la grosse nouveauté qu'on
a ici au niveau de l'album partagé c'est
que vous pouvez ajouter jusqu'à 6 amis
donc six personnes qui vont venir
partager ajouter chacune de leurs côtés
des photos si par exemple vous fêtez un
anniversaire que vous faites une fête ou
quoi que ce soit et bien plein de
personnes vont faire des photos et si
elles ont un iPhone elles peuvent venir
rajouter leurs propres photos dans
l'album à savoir ici que l'espace iCloud
sera pris sur le compte de la personne
qui a créé l'album partagé et non pas
sur le compte des autres autre nouveauté
je suis passé là vraiment vous
intéresser pour y venir supprimer
l'application carte qui est directement
ici avant vous pouvez pas le faire ça
fait partie des applications intégrées
directement par Apple ici on peut venir
la supprimer vous avez qu'à faire un
appui long dessus ici vous faites
supprimer l'app et là après supprimer
l'application tout court ou supprimer de
la page d'accueil vous pouvez donc la
supprimer si vous ne souhaitez pas la
conserver bon moi je vais la garder j'en
ai encore besoin comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure lorsque vous avez une
activité en direct qui est lancée ici
vous voyez vous le retrouvez par exemple
ici vous l'avez également en haut ici au
niveau de Dynamic Island et lorsque vous
avez du contenu quel qu'il soit au
niveau dynamic Island et que vous ne
souhaitez pas qu'il apparaisse en tout
cas que vous souhaitez le cacher pendant
un temps et bien c'est très facile vous
prenez votre doigt et vous glissez sur
le côté ça vient le cacher on a
l'impression qu'il y a plus rien et pour
le faire réapparaître vous glissez alors
d'un côté ou de l'autre ça marche dans
les deux sens après vous cliquez dessus
hop ça vous offre votre contenu vous le
refermez hop et vous voulez le cacher
vous glissez donc ça ça me fait marrer
petite astuce mais elle est très
pratique autre astuce est plutôt
pratique lorsque vous voulez venir
utiliser votre iPhone à une main vous
faites quoi vous glissez vers le bas hop
ça vous le descend sauf que maintenant
ça vous descend également d'un Mik
Island alors vous avez toujours votre
petite encoche qui est situé juste là et
que vous retrouvez là donc ce truc là
est plutôt pratique vous pouvez
également venir voyez glisser sur le
côté pour venir cacher bon bah là comme
je l'enregistrement de l'écran on le
voit quand même et vous remontez donc le
truc qui est plutôt pas mal et lorsque
vous voyez que ça remonte ici vous avez
un peu les deux qui se mettent en même
temps vous voyez hop là regard bien le
haut là paf ça revient ça va dedans
pratique malin belle mise à jour autre
nouveauté qu'on retrouve ici sur iOS
16.1 l'application forme inclut fitness
plus qui arrive avant vous pouviez avoir
uniquement fitness plus si vous aviez
une Apple watch maintenant vous pouvez
l'avoir directement dans votre iPhone
donc dans forme ça se situe juste en bas
vous venez ici sur fitness plus et là
vous trouvez votre application vous
pouvez venir souscrire un abonnement ce
que je n'ai pas encore fait mais vous
avez déjà trois mois gratuits plutôt
bien pour faire du sport pratiquer à la
maison entre nous voter qui est plutôt
bien fichu intéressant c'est au niveau
du mode Concentration alors je vous
explique vous venez ici dans vos
réglages et vous venez dans
concentration alors soit vous avez déjà
différents modes et que vous avez tout
paramétré et que tout va bien c'est
pratique ok mais si vous souhaitez venir
en créer un et bien vous cliquez ici
vous propose différents modes par défaut
conduite jeux vidéo lecture pleine
conscience sport il n'y a personnalisé
mais si par exemple vous voulez aller
sur jeux vidéo et bien ils ont fait un
nouvel écran qui vous explique comment
ça fonctionne et en quoi ça correspond
au monde du jeu vidéo ici donc là vous
l'avez effectivement pour jeux vidéo
vous l'avez pour conduite vous les ai
pour tous donc je trouve ça plus joli
plus compréhensible plus clair et ça
vous aidera aller plus loin dans votre
pleine conscience la dernière c'est pour
moi c'est cadeau vous venez ici sur
l'App Store vous cliquez ici et vous
venez actionner ça cette petite case au
niveau de téléchargement automatique
c'est contenu intégrés pourquoi parce
que il vous le marquent ça permettra
d'exécuter automatiquement les
applications en arrière-plan pour
télécharger leur contenu avant leur
premier lancement donc lorsque vous avez
téléchargé une application pour la
première fois ça viendra télécharger
tout le contenu dont on a besoin en
arrière-plan ça évitera que vous venez
vous le télécharger lorsque vous allez
lancer l'application bon allez je vous
ai donné les 11 mais j'en ai quand même
une petite dernière pour la route qui
est intéressante je vous montre lorsque
vous venez par exemple sur une
application qui est noire ou que vous
venez sur le thème sombre et bien il y a
une petite nouveauté vous voyez ils vous
ont fait un encadré pour que vous voyez
vraiment où est dynamic Island une fois
de plus lorsque vous êtes sur un iPhone
14 pro ou un iPhone 14 pro max donc ça
vient le rendre un peu plus lisible on
se dirait que là en fait on en a pas
besoin on veut la faire disparaître
cette petite buse cette petite encoche
mais non Apple il l'assume à 400% et on
vient la retrouver ici donc je trouve ça
assez malin alors là j'ai lancé
l'enregistrement regardez je vais
arrêter vous voyez là ici je l'ai plus
du tout ça me l'a caché mais pour autant
souvenez-vous on peut venir cacher du
contenu donc ce que je fais c'est que je
viens glisser légèrement ici et ça vient
de faire réapparaître mon contenu si
c'est mon application pour suivre les
vols et si je veux plus le voir je veux
le cacher je serais bien tout noir tout
noir et ben hop je fais ça je me mets
comme ça alors ça vous le voyez
directement avec l'application Horloge
mais lorsque je viens dans les réglages
que je viens dans luminosité et
affichage et je me mets en thème sombre
et bien regardez la même manière ici
c'est complètement sombre on le voit pas
il y a rien et je swive sur le côté ça
me fait réapparaître donc ça c'est
pratique vous voyez c'est complètement
caché et hop paf ça disparaît et là j'ai
mon petit contour qui revient voilà donc
c'est 12 nouveautés sur iOS 16.0 je sais
pas laquelle vous intéressez ce que vous
en connaissez d'autres des nouveautés
que j'aurais pas vu il y en a des
petites bricoles à des petits bouts
par-ci par là dites-le-moi on va en
commentaire et dites-moi si on a une qui
vous intéresserait réellement et que
vous allez venir utiliser au quotidien
voilà je vous embrasse prenez soin de
vous et à très bientôt pour d'autres
vidéos sur la tech Apple iPhone mais pas
que des bisous de l'amour à bientôt Ciao
[Musique]